there's a concept in Japanese Ma
it's the space between objects or
elements it's the time between the
beginning and the end it's the Gap the
space or pause
it's the negative space but Ma is not
simply an absence of things but an act
of presence that shapes the way we
perceive and interact with the world
around us it emphasizes the tension and
interplay between objects rather than
just focusing on the objects themselves
every Studio ghibling Movie will craft
these negative spaces and negative
moments with an incredible amount of
detail specifically sensory detail
even though movies are mainly a visual
and auditory medium in moments like this
you can almost feel the dampness on your
skin or the wind in your hair